alors que le port du masque tend à se
généraliser aujourd'hui la sncf a mené
une opération conjointe de contrôle avec
les forces de police
depuis le 11 mai le masque est
obligatoire dans les gares et dans les
trains
c'est une mesure que les voyageurs
comprennent et que la plupart appliquent
il n'y a pas de débat le virus repart
actuellement
les gestes barrière de base sont quand
même là précisément la meilleure
protection
il fait un petit peu chaud j'ai vu 36
sur dans ma voiture mais je préfère
avoir chaud qu'être à l'hôpital aux
urgences les voir de temps en temps se
balader je pense que ça rappelle à
certaines personnes que c'est pas que
même si elle a danger n'est pas visible
il est là donc c'est huit mois
tristement nécessaire on n'a pas eu de
chance aujourd'hui sinon d'habitude
c'est toujours avec le match et c'est
très important que notre propre santé
commandons ma première question c'est
est ce qu'on a constaté beaucoup de
verbalisation jusqu'à présent on a des
cas très marginaux et on est amené à
faire peu de verbalisation parce que
c'est une
ces obligations sont respectées on a
quand même des gens qui parfois ne
n'accepte pas la remarque de reporter au
procès d'alain maintenant désormais à la
répression
mais en matière de répression on a rêvé
très peu de verbalisation et jamais
jusqu'à présent de réitération dans les
quinze jours
cet après midi au cours de l'opération
trois personnes ont été verbalisées et
écope d'une amende de 135 euros